amber heard is giving her final day of
evidence in the johnny depp
libel trial against the sun amongst
today's revelations his former wife
described a time where she returned to
her house to find
mashed potato smeared on the door and
blood on the walls
spivada robinson is at the high court
for us adele tell us more
yes that incident that you're referring
to happened in
march of 2015 when johnny deck was in
australia
filming for pirates of the caribbean the
couple had rented a house and she
said that during that time she was
subjected to a three-day hostage
situation during which she was
repeatedly physically assaulted by mr
depp she said she came back
one day after she said johnny depp
had been drinking and had been taking a
lot of drugs and she came across
mashed potato and gravy smeared on the
front door
when she entered the house there was a
bird flying around the window was broken
there was blood on walls on lampshades
there were messages written
on walls there was raw meat strewn on
the floor
and her nightgown had been wrapped up in
pieces of food as she put in it was a
meal that she was supposed to
make the night before but in the end she
hadn't made it and she said that
death metal was blasting in the
downstairs part of the house
and there was blood and glass everywhere
so much glass she said
also a ping pong table was broken now
we've seen photographs earlier on in the
court proceedings of that scene johnny
depp said that he wasn't
on dr on drugs at all and he said that
he'd actually been assaulted by amber
heard we also heard
from amber some text messages sent
between
ms heard and her mother early on in
their relationship in 2013
uh she'd sent a message to her mother
saying i feel like i'm on
a very fastening train that's about to
explode but i don't want to jump off and
leave my love behind
so i stay on the train even though i
know it's about to explode she carries
on he's nuts
mum violent and crazy i'm heartbroken
that this is who i love and that was
after what's become known as the
painting incident
during which she said that johnny depp
had become jealous
she had a painting on her wall from her
ex-wife
and he alleged to her that she'd been
having an affair with her ex-wife and
another person
which she denies and she says that he
ended up slapping her with the back of
his hand
and spraying her blood onto the wall
which of course he denies she has now
finished giving evidence uh in the libel
proceedings
just before she finished she was asked
whether or not she had benefited
financially
and her career-wise from this case she's
denied that she had she actually
said what woman has ever benefited from
being the victim of domestic violence
she said that actually she didn't want
to come to court
and air these allegations because she
didn't want the world or johnny depp's
children to know
the kind of man that he could be she
actually said sometimes he was
remarkable generous
and loving at the times he was a monster
we're now hearing from her sister
whitney henriquez who is continuing to
give evidence at the moment
and she's talking out about a particular
staircase incident
during which she said that her sister
amber heard had punched johnny depp
amber heard has previously admitted this
because she said she thought
that she was protecting her sister
whitney so the trial continues and we
continue to hear
from whitney henry